when do the infected die HBO's TV
adaptation of the last of us has
featured several different types of
infected and I'm here to show you the
entire life cycle of an infected from
the first bite all the way to when the
fungus completely overtakes their body
most of all though I'll show you exactly
when the infected actually died but
let's start off from the beginning the
first bite the cordyceps fungal
infection spreads through direct contact
with an infected via a bite or
indirectly via Airborne fungal spores
released by a corpse these spores can
quickly infect an individual making
breathing difficult and movement
sluggish within only minutes of exposure
in Spore dense areas the fungus infects
the human brain growing mycelium inside
the brain tissue and killing the brain
cells this erases memories and drives
the host insane modifying their
instincts to seek no goal other than
spreading the spores to others the
infection can turn an individual into a
runner in as quickly as 5 minutes or up
to two days depending on where they were
bitten the bitten area will turn red and
black causing the host to sweat
profusely and become disoriented they
also show a Telltale sign of the
infection through their handshaking and
rapid muscle spasms relying on primitive
animalistic instincts caused by the
infection they'll attempt to attack or
eat any human they find which brings us
to the first type of infected a runner
Runners are individuals who recently
came into contact with the cordyceps
infection they're defined by their
intense speed sluggish attacks and a
tendency to attack people in hordes
Runners appear to experience hair loss
discolored skin accompanied with lesions
and bloodshot eyes another interesting
thing the HBO adaptation added to the
infected's abilities is somewhat of a
hive mind as seen in the series if one
infected or fungal growth is stimulated
other infected runners in the area will
be alerted causing them to attack the
stimulated area in large masses stalkers
are creatures who have been infected
from somewhere between two weeks to a
year per their name they stalk and hide
from prey in the dark and attack at
opportune moments some also latch onto
the walls and allow the cordyceps to
Fester keeping the host alive until prey
walks by at which point the stalker
breaks free and attacks stalkers can be
seen with significant fungal growth
around their eyes and shoulder Builders
skin will begin to peel from the face
sometimes causing the nose to fall off
as the fungus begins to break open the
skull clickers are creatures that have
been infected for at least one year by
this point the skull has been completely
split open due to Advanced fungal growth
on the brain growing over or outright
destroying the host's eyes leaving only
a mob of teeth which are rotten and
Jagged these growths eventually blind
them forcing them to use a rudimentary
form of echolocation to find their prey
however the fungus grants them enhanced
strength making them stronger than
typical humans and quite dangerous in
close quarters combat clickers can often
be seen erratically twitching and
sometimes clawing at the fungal growth
covering their face strongly suggesting
that there's some remaining element of
the host attempting to resist the fungus
even in the later stages of infection
due to their blindness clickers begin to
produce loud clicking and croaking
sounds which survivors can clearly hear
allowing them to evade detection by
these infected as long as they remain
silent bloaters have been infected for
more than two years the fungus has led
them to become slow and blind yet
incredibly strong and resilient with the
fungi growth serving as armor plating
floaters can also tear fungus from their
bodies to use as Spore bombs and throw
them at their enemies however this
additional fungal growth makes them more
vulnerable to fire the fungal growth on
bloaters is so Advanced that it begins
to form armor and plates on the host
while also causing the body to bloat
significantly giving them their nickname
the fungus also seems to offer the host
some protection against the elements
such as the cold and water shamblers are
creatures that have been infected for
even longer than bloaters and typically
inhabit areas thriving with water while
not as physically enhanced as clickers
or bloaters shimblers are able to
Grapple prey and expel large Spore
clouds from their bodies which cause
acidic burns on the skin of prey when
killed the spores explode releasing a
final burst of cordyceps into the air
infecting anyone around them the rad
King is a unique stage of infected that
developed in a Seattle hospital after
over 20 years of infection formed from
several infected combining into one the
Rat King is colossal in strength and
size and able to take extensive damage
from fire bombs and guns even after
taking much of dam image it doesn't die
but instead its various infected parts
will start to break off from the larger
mass and attack along with it now for
the question you've been waiting for
when do they eventually die well if you
don't count humans killing them during
one of the earlier stages of infection
the answer is that it varies for example
stalkers often enter dormant States
latching onto walls and allowing the
fungus to grow around them until they're
Disturbed if they aren't Disturbed for
an extended period of time though the
fungus will eventually kill the host
body there are some Infected who only
live for a few weeks and others that can
survive for over 20 years such as the
Rat King a lot of an infected's lifespan
is dependent upon environmental
conditions and other outside factors
while a host's body size and weight also
play into the lifespan external factors
impact it more also while the infected
have a higher pain tolerance than
ordinary humans they're still
susceptible to injuries and can be
killed through conventional means a
runner when not attacking survivors will
moan in pain due to the fungal growth
deforming its body and clickers will
struggle while being stabbed sometimes
in infected that still have their entire
face intact look remorseful or
distressed as they attack indicating
that the infected are aware of what
they're doing but can't control
themselves gunshots are capable of
startling Runners and stalkers
indicating that feelings like fear are
still prominent in the early stages of
infection so maybe the better question
isn't how long can an infected survive
but rather wind isn't infected lose its
Humanity now keep in mind this
information on the types of infected and
when they die comes from a mixture of
both the video games and the TV show so
we may see more differences in the HBO
series as more seasons are released
anyways subscribe for more The Last of
Us content and if you liked the video
check out the one on your screen too
foreign